steven spielberg said you find yourself  in the podium remember  that you are part of a legacy that  you're part of a world of filmmakers and  be proud of it i'm very very proud thank  you very much thank you gracias  oh my god i just want to thank all of  you thank you so much  gracias gracias  thank you thank you thank you  specifically  foreign  is the result because mommy worked so  hard  i want to dedicate this award to all the  heroes working on the ground in pakistan  i'm always going to fight for my people  and fight for what's right and that's  and that's what storytelling does art in  any form has been and will always be our  universal language muchisimar gracias  thank you so much peace love and onwards  we go again  and i thank you all very much